[Music]
i saw
a month or two ago in an italian paper
that the villa cascana
in which i once stayed had been pulled
down and that a manufactory of some sort
was in process of erection on its site
there is therefore no longer any reason
for refraining from writing of those
things which i myself saw
or imagined i saw in a certain room and
on a certain landing of the villa in
question
nor from mentioning the circumstances
which followed
which may or may not according to the
opinion of the reader
throw some light on or be somehow
connected with this experience
the villa cascana was in always but one
a perfectly delightful house yet if it
were standing now
nothing in the world i use the phrase in
its literal sense
would induce me to set foot in it again
for i believe it to have been haunted
in a very terrible and practical manner
most ghosts when all is said and done do
not do much harm
they may perhaps terrify but the person
whom they visit
usually gets over their visitation they
may on the other hand
be entirely friendly and beneficent
but the appearances in the villa cascana
were not beneficent
and had they made their visit in a very
slightly different manner
i do not suppose i should have got over
it any more than arthur inglis did
the house stood on an ilex clad hill not
far
from cestri di levante on the italian
riviera
looking out over the iridescent blues of
that enchanted sea
while behind it rose the pale green
chestnut woods
that climb up the hillsides till they
give place to the pines that black in
contrast with them
crown the slopes all rounded the garden
and the luxuriance of mid-spring bloomed
and was fragrant
and the scent of magnolia and rose born
on the salt freshness of the winds from
the sea
flowed like a stream through the cool
vaulted rooms
on the ground floor a broad pillared
logia ran
round three sides of the house the top
of which formed a balcony for certain
rooms of the first floor
the main staircase broad and of gray
marble steps
led up from the hall to the landing
outside these rooms which were three in
number
namely two big sitting rooms and a
bedroom arranged ensuite
the ladder was unoccupied the sitting
rooms were in use
from these the main staircase was
continued to the second floor
where were situated certain bedrooms one
of which i
occupied while from the other side of
the first floor landing
some half dozen steps led to another
suite of rooms
where at the time i am speaking of
arthur inglis the artist
had his bedroom and studio thus the
landing outside my bedroom at the top of
the house
commanded both the landing of the first
floor and also
the steps that led to english's rooms
jim stanley and his wife finally whose
guest i was
occupied rooms in another wing of the
house where were also the servant's
quarters
i arrived just in time for lunch on a
brilliant noon of mid-may
the garden was shouting with color and
fragrance and not less delightful after
my broiling walk up from the marina
should have been the coming from the
reverberating heat and blaze of the day
into the marble coolness of the villa
only
the reader has my bare word for this and
nothing more
the moment i set foot in the house i
felt that something was wrong
this feeling i may say was quite vague
though very strong
and i remember that when i saw letters
waiting for me on the table in the hall
i felt certain that the explanation was
here i was convinced that there was bad
news of some sort for me
yet when i opened them i found no such
explanation of my premonition
my correspondence all reeked of
prosperity
yet this clear miscarriage of a
pre-sentiment did not dissipate my
uneasiness
in that cool fragrant house there was
something wrong
i'm at pains to mention this because to
the general view
it may explain that though i am as a
rule so excellent a sleeper
that the extinction of my light on
getting into bed
is apparently contemporaneous with being
called on the following morning
i slept very badly on my first night in
the villa cascana
it may also explain the fact that when i
did sleep
if it was indeed in sleep that i saw
what i thought i saw
i dreamed in a very vivid and original
manner
original that is to say in the sense
that something that as far as i knew
had never previously entered into my
consciousness usurped it then
but since in addition to this evil
premonition
certain words and events occurring
during the rest of the day
might have suggested something of what i
thought happened that night
it will be well to relate them after
lunch then
i went round the house with mrs stanley
and during our tour
she referred it as true to the
unoccupied bedroom
on the first floor which opened out of
the room where we had lunched
we left that unoccupied she said because
jim and i have a charming bedroom and
dressing room as you saw
in the wing and if we used it ourselves
we should have to turn the dining room
into a dressing room and have our meals
downstairs
as it is however we have our little flat
there
arthur inglis has his little flat in the
other passage
and i remembered aren't i extraordinary
that you once said that the higher up
you were in a house
the better you were pleased so i put you
at the top of the house
instead of giving you that room it is
true
that a doubt vague is my uneasy
premonition
crossed my mind at this i did not see
why mrs stanley should have explained
all this
if there had not been more to explain i
allow therefore
that the thought that there was
something to explain about the
unoccupied bedroom
was momentarily present to my mind
the second thing that may have borne on
my dream was this
at dinner the conversation turned for a
moment on ghosts
inglis with a certainty of conviction
expressed his belief that anybody who
could possibly believe in the existence
of supernatural phenomena
was unworthy of the name of an ass the
subject
instantly dropped as far as i can
recollect
nothing else occurred or was said that
could bear on what follows
we all went to bed rather early and i
personally yawned my way upstairs
feeling hideously sleepy my room was
rather hot
and i threw all the windows wide and
from without poured in the white light
of the moon
and the love song of many nightingales
i undressed quickly and got into bed but
though i had felt so sleepy before
i now felt extremely wide awake but i
was quite content to be awake
i did not toss or turn i felt perfectly
happy listening to the song and seeing
the light
then it is possible i may have gone to
sleep
and what follows may have been a dream
i thought anyhow that after a time the
nightingale ceased singing and the moon
sank i thought also that if
for some unexplained reason i was going
to lie awake all night
i might as well read and i remembered
that i had left a book in which i was
interested in the dining room on the
first floor
so i got out of bed lit a candle and
went downstairs
i went into the room saw on a side table
the book i had come to look for
and then simultaneously saw that the
door into the unoccupied bedroom
was open a curious gray light
not of dawn nor of moonshine came out of
it
and i looked in the bed stood just
opposite the door
a big four poster hung with tapestry at
the head
then i saw that the grayish light of the
bedroom came from the bed
or rather from what was on the bed
for it was covered with great
caterpillars a foot or more in length
which crawled over it they were faintly
luminous
and it was the light from them that
showed me the room
instead of the sucker feet of ordinary
caterpillars
they had rows of pinchers like crabs and
they moved by grasping what they lay on
with their pinchers
and then sliding their bodies forward
in color these dreadful insects were
yellowish gray
and they were covered with irregular
lumps and swellings there must have been
hundreds of them
for they formed a sort of writhing
crawling pyramid on the bed
occasionally one fell off onto the floor
with a soft fleshy thud
and though the floor was of hard
concrete it yielded
to the pincher feet as if it had been
putty and crawling back
the caterpillar would mount onto the bed
again to rejoin its fearful companions
they appeared to have no faces so to
speak
but at one end of them there was a mouth
that opened sideways in respiration
then as i looked it seemed to me as if
they all suddenly became
conscious of my presence all the mouths
at any rate were turned in my direction
and next moment they began dropping off
the bed with those soft fleshy thuds
onto the floor
and wriggling towards me for one second
a paralysis
as of a dream was on me but the next i
was running upstairs again to my room
and i remember feeling the cold of the
marble steps on my bare feet
i rushed into my bedroom and slammed the
door behind me
and then i was certainly wide awake now
i found myself standing by my bed with
the sweat of terror pouring from me
the noise of the banged door still rang
in my ears
but as would have been more usual if
this had been a mere nightmare
the terror that had been mine when i saw
those foul beasts crawling about the bed
or dropping softly onto the floor did
not cease then
awake now if dreaming before i did not
at all recover from the horror of dream
it did not seem to me that i had dreamed
and until dawn
i sat or stood not daring to lie down
thinking that every rustle or movement
that i heard was the approach of the
caterpillars
to them and the claws that bit into the
cement the wood of the door was child's
play
steel would not keep them out but with
the sweet and noble return of day
the horror vanished the whisper of wind
became benign again
the nameless fear whatever it was was
smoothed out
and terrified me no longer dawn broke
hewless at first then it grew
dove-colored
then the flaming pageant of light spread
over the sky
the admirable rule of the house was that
everybody had breakfast
where and when he pleased and in
consequence it was not till lunchtime
that i met any of the other members of
our party since i had breakfast on my
balcony
and wrote letters and other things till
lunch
in fact i got down to that meal rather
late after the other three had begun
between my knife and fork there was a
small pill box of cardboard
and as i sat down inglis spoke
do look at that he said since you are
interested in natural history
i found it crawling on my counter pain
last night and i don't know what it is
i think that before i opened the pillbox
i expected something of the sort which i
found in it
inside it anyhow was a small caterpillar
grayish yellow in color
with curious bumps and excrescences on
its rings
it was extremely active and hurried
round the box
this way in that its feet were unlike
the feet of any caterpillar i ever saw
they were like the pinchers of a crab i
looked
and shut the lid down again no
i don't know it i said but it looks
rather unwholesome
what are you going to do with it oh i
shall keep it
said english it has begun to spin i want
to see what sort of a moth it turns into
i opened the box again and saw that
these hurrying movements were indeed the
beginning of the spinning of the web of
its cocoon
then inglis spoke again it's got funny
feet too
he said they're like crabs pinchers
what's the latin for crab
oh yes cancer so in case it is unique
let's christen it cancer inglisensis
then something happened in my brain some
momentary piecing together of all that i
had seen or dreamed
something in his words seemed to me to
throw light on it all
and my own intense horror at the
experience of the night before
linked itself on to what he had just
said
in effect i took the box and threw it
caterpillar and all
out of the window there was a gravel
path just outside
and beyond it a fountain playing into a
basin
the box fell onto the middle of this
inglis laughed
so the students of the occult don't like
solid facts he said
my poor caterpillar the talk went off
again at once onto other subjects
and i have only given in detail as they
happened these trivialities
in order to be sure myself that i have
recorded everything that could have
borne on occult subjects
or on the subject of caterpillars but at
the moment when i threw the pillbox into
the fountain
i lost my head my only excuse is that as
is probably plain the tenet of it was in
miniature
exactly what i had seen crowded onto the
bed in the unoccupied room
and though this translation of those
phantoms into flesh and blood
or whatever it is that caterpillars are
made of ought perhaps to have relieved
the horror of the night
as a matter of fact it did nothing of
the kind
it only made the crawling pyramid that
covered the bed in the unoccupied room
more hideously real after lunch we spent
a lazy
hour or two strolling about the garden
or sitting in the logia and it must have
been about four o'clock when stanley and
i started off to bathe
down the path that led by the fountain
into which i had thrown the pillbox
the water was shallow and clear and at
the bottom of it i saw its white remains
the water had disintegrated the
cardboard and it had become no more than
a few strips and shreds of sod and paper
the center of the fountain was a marble
italian cupid which squirted the water
out of a wine skin
held under its arm and crawling up its
leg
was the caterpillar strange and scarcely
credible as it seemed
it must have survived the falling to
bits of its prison
and made its way to shore and there it
was
out of arm's reach weaving and waving
this way and that
as it evolved its cocoon then
as i looked at it it seemed to me again
that like the caterpillar i had seen
last night
it saw me and breaking out of the
threads that surrounded it
it crawled down the marble leg of the
cupid and began
swimming like a snake across the water
of the fountain towards me
it came with extraordinary speed the
fact of a caterpillar being able to swim
was new to
me and in another moment was crawling up
the marble lip of the basin
just then english joined us why if it is
an old cancer anglocensus again
he said catching sight of the beast what
a tearing hurry it is in
we were standing side by side on the
path and when the caterpillar had
advanced to within about a yard of us
it stopped and began waving again as if
in doubt as to the direction in which it
should go
then it appeared to make up its mind and
crawled onto inglis's shoe
it likes me best he said but i don't
really know that i like it
and as it won't drown i think perhaps
he shook it off his shoe onto the gravel
path and trot on it
all afternoon the air got heavier and
heavier with the sirocco that was
without doubt coming up from the south
and that night again i went up to bed
feeling very sleepy
but below my drowsiness so to speak
there was the consciousness
stronger than before that there was
something wrong in the house
that something dangerous was close at
hand
but i fell asleep at once and how long
after i do not know
either woke or dreamed i awoke feeling
that i must get up at once
or i should be too late then
dreaming or awake i lay and fought this
fear
telling myself that i was but the prey
of my own nerves
disordered by sirocco or whatnot and at
the same time quite clearly knowing in
another part of my mind so to speak
that every moment's delay added to the
danger at last this second feeling
became irresistible
and i put on coat and trousers and went
out of my room onto the landing
and then i saw that i had already
delayed too long
and that i was now too late the hole of
the landing of the first floor below
was invisible under the swarm of
caterpillars that crawled there
the folding doors into the sitting room
from which opened the bedroom where i
had seen them last night were shut
but they were squeezing through the
cracks of it and dropping one by one
through the keyhole
elongating themselves into mere string
as they passed
and growing fat and lumpy again on
emerging
some as if exploring were nosing about
the steps into the passage at the end of
which were inglis's rooms
others were crawling on the lowest steps
of the staircase that led up to where i
stood
the landing however was completely
covered with them
i was cut off and of the frozen horror
that seized me when i saw that
i can give no idea in words
then at last a general movement began to
take place
and they grew thicker on the steps that
led to inglis's room
gradually like some hideous tide of
flesh
they advanced along the passage and i
saw the foremost
visible by the pale gray luminousness
that came from them
reach his door again and again i tried
to shout and warn him
in terror all the time that they would
turn at the sound of my voice
and mount my stare instead but for all
my efforts i felt that no
sound came from my throat they crawled
along the hinge crack of his door
passing through as they had done before
and still i stood there
making impotent efforts to shout to him
to bid him escape while there was still
time
at last the passage was completely empty
they had all gone
and at that moment i was conscious for
the first time
of the cold of the marble landing on
which i stood barefooted
the dawn was just beginning to break in
the eastern sky
six months after i met mrs stanley in a
country house in england
we talked on many subjects and at last
she said
i don't think i have seen you since i
got that dreadful news about arthur
inglis a month ago
i haven't heard said i no
he's got cancer they don't even advise
an operation
for there is no hope of a cure he is
riddled with it the doctors say
now during all these six months i do not
think a day had passed on which i had
not had in my mind the dreams or
whatever you like to call them
which i had seen in the villa cascana
it is awful is it not she continued
and i feel i can't help feeling that he
may have
caught it at the villa i asked she
looked at me in blank surprise
why did you say that she asked how did
you know
then she told me in the unoccupied
bedroom
a year before there had been a fatal
case of cancer
she had of course taken the best advice
and had been told that the utmost
dictates of prudence would be obeyed
so long as she did not put anybody to
sleep in that room
which had also been thoroughly
disinfected and newly whitewashed and
painted
but
stephen didn't see the moth at first it
was fairly well camouflaged against the
bathroom wall
but once he saw it he found that he
couldn't unsee it
the thing was huge easily bigger than
his small spread palm
maybe even bigger than his father's hand
its wings looked soft and furry
and steven wondered what it would be
like to touch them to rub the insectile
hairs across his cheek
he shuddered with combined pleasure and
revulsion at the thought
its coloring was odd and sort of ugly
steven had to admit
the wings were a particularly
unappealing shade of yellow broken up
with asymmetrical streaks of dirty brown
piss and [ __ ] steven thought and then
giggled to himself
he glanced around to see if anyone had
come in behind him if anyone had heard
him thinking the forbidden words
no one had he stared up at the moth
again
it made sense though he mused once his
boyish mirth had passed for the moth to
be
those colors he remembered seeing a
program on tv about camouflage
about how animals evolved to blend into
their environments
and this was a place for piss and [ __ ]
after all this the moths environment
steven's eyes sparkled as he looked at
it the walls around the insect were a
similar pissy yellow
as if painted by the very stench of the
place as if what went on in there had
left its permanent mark
there were even streaks of a brownish
something or other here and there on the
walls
maybe it was paint maybe it was another
thing steven went a bit green thinking
about that
he crept a little closer to the moth but
it didn't stir
it probably didn't feel threatened since
it was perched far up on the wall close
to the ceiling
stephen didn't think he could reach it
even if he balanced himself on the
toilet seat in the farthest stall and
stretched his arm all the way out
not that he had any intention of doing
that he had been in the john long enough
as it was
and if he didn't hurry up his father
would be along looking for him
steven's stomach clenched he hated
camping and he hadn't wanted to come
along on this trip
especially with only his father and his
younger sister it would have been better
if mom had come
reluctantly he took his eyes away from
his new friend the freakishly huge piss
and [ __ ] moth
and went about the business he'd tramped
up here for there was one high window
across the length of the back wall
no glass just a rectangle cut neatly out
of the concrete
steven could see the sunlight filtering
through the treetops and hear the
twittering of birds and the far away
sounds of children laughing
splashing around in the springs a short
distance away
he finished peeing and pulled his trunks
back up glancing sideways up at the moth
as he did so
it hadn't moved he wondered how long it
had been sitting there
he had just washed his hands and was
drying them on his shorts because the
paper towel dispenser was empty
when he heard footsteps crunching in the
fallen leaves outside
his heart lurched in his chest and he
turned coiling the muscles in his legs
to prepare for a sprint
but then a stranger walked in an old man
with a fringe of white hair
the man smiled absently at him and
disappeared into one of the stalls
steven's held breath stuttered out like
a dying boat motor
with one last look at the gigantic
insect he ducked out of the bathroom and
began trotting down the rough dirt path
that led back to the campgrounds in the
springs
it was late august and the sun hammered
down like a judgment
trying to boil everything upon the
surface of the earth stephen wiped sweat
from his face with the back of his hand
thinking of how good the cool clear
water would feel on his skin
he planned to run the last 20 feet of
the path and plunge into the water all
at once
making a massive splash relishing the
blue ice enveloping him utterly and
cradling him
he passed their campsite with its small
red dome of a tent the remnants of a
fire
wet towel slung over low branches both
his father and tricia were down at the
water
most everyone was almost all of the
campsites looked deserted
the springs loomed ahead the still water
seeming to warp and shimmer in the
relentless heat
people dotted the small crescent of
beach that hugged the shore
kids ran back and forth couples
languished on blankets
their bodies crimson and sizzling steven
could make out the back of his father's
head
the greasy dark hair that always looked
scraggly at the back flopping over his
collar
steven remembered that his mother always
complained about how fast his father's
hair grew
how often he had to have it cut when she
did his father would usually just tell
her to shut her mouth
steven wondered why she kept bringing it
up trisha was playing at the shoreline
digging in the sugary sand with her
little green shovel she didn't know how
to swim yet
as steven watched the little girl grew
tired of digging and began slapping the
shovel on the surface of the water
making crystal droplets fly in all
directions
the sound it made delighted her so much
that she squealed loudly in time with
the rhythmic slaps
squeal blatt squeal blatt after a few
moments steven heard his father's voice
roaring god damn it tricia stop that
noise or i'll beat your ass
trisha stopped and even from this
distance stephen could see the kid's
bottom lip beginning to tremble
steven sent a mental stream of hate at
the back of his father's head
so white hot and tangible that he was
surprised that his father didn't feel it
didn't turn around and fix him with
those steel cold eyes
stephen sauntered down to the beach
forgetting his earlier plan to run and
jump into the water
he passed his father's chair and nodded
in acknowledgement his father simply
looked at him
brows knitted in a stern v trisha looked
up at her older brother when he
approached and smiled her sunny smile at
him
she wasn't dark like steven and his
father but pale fragile cherubic
she had their mother's curly blonde hair
and wide innocent blue eyes
which were now ringed with red steven
bent down and kissed the top of her head
having fun kiddo he asked she goggled at
him waving the shovel around
and said something that sounded like a
low cv then laughed at her unmangling of
the words
steven laughed too the good laughter
like a shared secret
i'm going in the water so just stay here
near daddy he told her and she stared at
him eyes like polished marbles
he didn't know she understood but she
didn't follow him as he waded into the
shallow part of the spring
stephen walked farther out the sand like
velvet under his toes
except where the occasional shell
fragment would rear up out of the depths
and bite with serrated edges
once his feet couldn't touch the bottom
anymore he stretched himself out
and began to glide through the water
fancying himself a dolphin or an otter
wicking the droplets from his body as he
dove down came back
up dove down again he opened his eyes
underwater and looked all around
his cheeks puffed out with trapped air
bubbles leaking from his lips tickling
them
off to the right and in front of him was
a dark forest of waving seaweed slick
with furry algae
the fur reminded him of the moths wings
and with a delicious anticipation he
thought of going back into the bathroom
later tonight
perhaps after his father was asleep to
see if the moth was still there
maybe he'd even see it out hunting for
food its piss and [ __ ] colored wings
whirring in the humid august night
as it descended like an angel of death
upon its prey
steven swam off to the left towards the
boil where the pleasantly warm water
erupted from deep in the earth
he went briefly to the surface to take a
breath then plunge back down again
chasing after the tiny silver fish that
darted in formation through the lazy
green stalks at the bottom
there were divers down in the boil and
the rocks down there glittered like
newly fallen snow banks against the
sleek black of their wetsuits
steven watched them for a moment and
then popped back up to the surface
flicking his longish black hair away
from his face
it was so hot that he could almost feel
himself withering
he lowered himself into the water until
only the top of his head above his nose
was visible
then paddled with his arms and legs
making circles so that the currents of
the warmish water eddied around him
buoying him up
he peered down at his distorted forearms
through the surface of the water
amused by the fragmented funhouse effect
the slant of sunlight through the
ripples made his skin appear blue
like the fabulous sheen of a mermaid in
one of his story books at home
i'm camouflaged he thought waving his
arms back and forth
enjoying the weight of the water as he
pushed through it no one can see me
no one can get me i can swoop down on
those insects with my enormous blue
wings and they'll never see me coming
he wasn't sure how long he floated there
staring at his arms
he felt his legs beginning to get heavy
and sore and it became harder to keep
his nose above the surface
the light seemed different the sun lower
in the sky its glare not so punishing
steven dipped his head back under then
came up spluttering a little
smoothing his hair back again the water
left a moldy green taste in his mouth
his fingers were all pruny like when he
had been in the bathtub too long
he swam back toward the shore using long
live strokes
when he got near enough he felt for the
sandy bottom with his feet and walked
the rest of the way up
his father was still in his chair but
now he was snoring with his brows
knitted in their perpetual expression of
displeasure
trisha was sleeping too fitfully her
shovel clutched in her tiny hand
steven noted that her cheeks and nose
were red with sunburn and he glared at
his snoring father
annoyed that he hadn't thought to put
sunscreen on the child
people were starting to drift back to
their campsites carrying their lounge
chairs and coolers
shoulders slumped in brown hair
bedraggled it was almost supper time
and everyone would be starting up the
fires and grills soon sending the
wonderful summery smells of burgers and
hot dogs and steaks spiraling into the
twilight
steven realized he was hungry he
considered waking his father but was
reluctant to do so
with a sigh he again wished his mother
were here to take care of these things
she would wake him up even if he yelled
at her or slapped her across the mouth
for doing it
steven turned and looked out across the
spring the water was darkening
taking on a deeper blue color that would
soon become purple then black as the
night fell across
it he remembered the look of his arms
under the water
part of the water the blue of his skin
and the blue of the water
blue and blue yellow and yellow brown
and brown
maybe his father didn't wake up because
steven wasn't even there
he was camouflaged against the water
invisible
with a shrug he began walking up the
dirt path toward the campgrounds
his bare feet were wrinkly and sensitive
from their long soak and every rock and
shell that they encountered made stephen
wince
he could hear people's voices laughter
and snatches of songs from someone's
radio
the trees around him stretched up to
forever protecting him from the eye of
the fading sun
he fled in among the trees pretending he
was flapping his soft furry wings
pretending they were the same color as
the tree trunks no one else was on the
path around him
they were all up ahead or still on the
beach they wouldn't have been able to
see him anyway
the campsite looked the same as it had
before with the red tent and the damp
towels on the branches
there was activity now though in the
other campsites that were just visible
through the trees
he could see the orange glow from the
fires smiling faces lit by the flames
he could smell food cooking hear the
clink of glass and cutlery
his stomach rumbled steven crawled
through the tent flap on his hands and
knees
poking around in his sleeping bag for
his jeans and t-shirt
he found some clean underwear in his
backpack and rolled all the clothes up
into a bundle that he stuck under his
arm
it wasn't dark enough yet to need the
flashlight he backed out of the tent and
took his bundle up the path toward the
bathroom
the air seemed to be coming alive with
the sound of buzzing and clicking
tiny insects and creatures waking from
their daylight slumbers and taking wing
to eat or be eaten every night was a
gamble
the bathroom was empty when he reached
it for which he was grateful
the light over the sink was dirty and
flickered intermittently as if
threatening to give up altogether
but the glassless window gave enough
light to see by sunset light orange and
pink and lavender
his bundle of clothes still in his arms
steven glanced up to the ceiling near
the farthest stall
the moth was still there and the exact
same place it had been earlier in the
afternoon
it seemed bigger but steven thought that
was probably his imagination
its piss yellow wings lay flat against
the piss yellow wall
looking as soft as goose down stephen
hurried out of his wet swimsuit and into
his dry clothes
trying not to take his eyes off the moth
it's sad
stoic even its antennae motionless
steven thought for a second that it
might be dead and the idea sent a cold
chill up his spine despite the
smothering heat
but just then the moth flexed its great
wings like a person stretching after a
long restoring sleep
steven's whole body spasmed in surprise
and his damp shorts fell with a muffled
splat at his feet
he stared gate-mouthed as the moth took
flight first fluttering over to
investigate the dingy light fixture
then hovering at the window as though
peering out into the night
searching for something or someone
steven swore that he could feel the
displaced air from the flap of the moths
wings
it caressed his face like his mother's
breath
it seemed as though an eternity passed
while the moth fluttered there back and
forth along the length of the window as
though patrolling the grounds
stephen stood rooted to the spot his
trunks cold on his toes
suddenly the moth dived away from the
window and resumed its post on the wall
laying its wings flat against the yellow
paint again
steven wondered what it had seen friend
or foe but then his question was
answered when a small mosquito cruised
into the bathroom through the
rectangular gap
twizzling about in that ass-hanging way
that mosquitoes had
forever on the lookout for blood steven
waved it away when it came near his face
and as if sensing the snub the mosquito
lifted its ungainly body toward the
ceiling
toward where the moth lay hidden in
plain sight against the wall
it happened so fast that stephen wasn't
sure he had seen it
when the mosquito came within a few
inches of the monstrous moth
the great yellow and brown wings flapped
once propelling the giant insect's body
away from the wall
and like a hawk dropping into a field
scooping up a terrified mouse or rabbit
and carrying it kicking and shrieking
through the sky in its scaly claws
the moth descended on the mosquito its
shadow falling across the much smaller
insect like a kite's shadow across the
ground
and then the mosquito was simply gone
its days of careless vampirism ended in
one fraction of a second
apparently sated the moth settled back
into its place among the piss and [ __ ]
stains on the wall
steven felt immobilized by the scene
still not believing what his eyes had
shown him
the ferocity of nature played out right
here in some stinking bathroom and some
filthy campground
somewhere out in the feeted swampy
wilderness for a moment it overwhelmed
him
the quickness with which life could be
snuffed out the lack of remorse felt by
the snuffer afterward
predator and prey eat or be eaten he
looked up at the moth with something
like awe
only the slight darkening at the edges
of its wings betrayed its position on
the wall
the sky outside the window had grown
dark and stars had begun to appear
between the branches
finally shaking himself breaking the
spell stephen bent and picked up his
shorts from the floor
they were mostly dry now he wondered if
his father and trisha had come back from
the beach
yet or if they were even now snoring
under the canopy of stars as the warm
water bubbled and lapped before them
boiling up from someplace down in the
core of the earth somewhere devils lived
it didn't matter steven supposed he was
camouflaged they wouldn't be able to see
him
waving goodbye to his moth which looked
even bigger now than it had when he'd
first come in
steven went out into the night listening
to the chirp of frogs and crickets
wondering how many of them would live to
see the dawn the smell of smoke and
cooking meat was very strong but he
didn't notice it so much now
he wasn't really that hungry anymore in
the one light from the far away fires
and from the lamps along the path
he began looking for a stick or a heavy
branch
his father was at the campsite sitting
in his chair with his back to the path
the glow from the fire in front of him
gave him a weird reddish orange aura a
neon outline
steven could see from the movement of
the tent that tricia was inside it
playing
he didn't bother about the noise his
feet were making on the leaves and pine
needles
he was camouflaged the black of the tree
trunks the red of the tent fabric the
orange of the flames the gray of the
smoke
no one could see him as he swooped down
on his prey invisible ghostly death
his father didn't even turn around as
steven swung the branch
stephanie guthrie stood in the center of
the pile of blood-soaked bodies
her arms outstretched her face a blank
mask
children pointed and screamed animals
paced in their cages
zoo employees gaped like statues unable
to believe what they had just seen
soon enough the police came to quell the
panic and then an ambulance came and
bundled the woman inside
i haven't been able to get a single word
out of her said teresa hill the police
psychologist
looks like partial catatonia vic
unger the lead investigator on what was
sure to be the most bizarre case the
city had ever seen
made a disgusted sound typical and wait
till you hear what we got back from the
lab guys
what's that the halls were nearly empty
in this ward and teresa's voice echoed
like a snatch of memory
cause of death for all 15 people at the
zoo vic said
was evidently a mass poisoning in other
words they were gassed
theresa raised her eyebrows at him
terrorists
vic shrugged that's why we need to get a
story out of the sole survivor in there
he scratched distractedly at his three
days growth of beard
she doesn't strike me as the terrorist
type i gotta say
no maybe the poison came from somewhere
else and miss guthrie was the only one
lucky enough to survive
it could be although witnesses say the
people around her dropped dead as soon
as she raised her arms
like the two events were related have
you done any scans on her or anything
checked her for brain damage yes looks
like nothing out of the ordinary
so far damn vic was a handsome man
only in his mid 30s but already
cultivating a look of hang dog cynicism
that teresa found amusing
they had reached the end of the hall and
the locked room where stephanie guthrie
was being held for observation
teresa produced a set of keys from the
pocket of her coat and opened the door
stephanie was sitting rigidly in the
chamber's only chair
her hands resting stiffly on her lap she
didn't look up as teresa and vic
entered but kept her gaze fixed on a
spot just below eye level
a very long moment passed before she
even blinked
hello there miss guthrie teresa stood
before the woman her arms crossed
how are we doing today stephanie of
course did not answer
the investigator is here miss guthrie
theresa continued gesturing to vic
who was standing slightly behind and to
the left of her
he'd really like to get to the bottom of
what happened at the zoo on saturday
do you think you'll be able to cooperate
more silence in which stephanie's chest
barely rose and fell with her breathing
vic stepped forward at teresa's urging
i'm vic unger miss guthrie he said
i'd like to help you but to do that i
need to ask you some questions
is that all right another blank another
breath
vic wasn't in the mood for this his
impatience was one of his few negative
attributes
can't you just hypnotize her or
something he asked
teresa stared down at the top of
stephanie's head
that may become necessary although i
have to tell you ahead of time that
hypnosis is sometimes not a very
effective psychiatric tool
we generally only use it as a last
resort
well can you get started on all the
other resorts i'd really like to figure
out what the hell is going on here
as would we all mr unger teresa smiled
at him
but cases like this take time i'm sure
you understand
vic nodded he did understand but he
didn't like it
the next day driving up the interstate
vic ran the facts of the case through
his mind again
hoping to stumble upon a detail he'd
missed the first few times
last saturday at approximately 2 15 pm
at the langford county zoo
thirty-two-year-old stephanie guthrie
had been strolling through the butterfly
garden in the company of her 36 year old
fiancee ray framington
according to witnesses the few who were
left alive that is
they had been holding hands and
stephanie had been smiling
then suddenly things had taken a macabre
turn
in an instant the woman had gone white
tilting her head slightly upwards as if
she had just heard something that
shocked her beyond her capacity to
reason
her eyes apparently glazed over and even
though ray framington had shaken her
trying to discern the problem she had
acted as though he wasn't even there
then witnesses agreed she had slowly
begun to raise her arms
until they were even with her shoulders
at the moment when she opened her hands
spreading her fingers to their farthest
extremes
the 15 people closest to her including
her fiance
had simultaneously begun to bleed from
every orifice
and after an agonizing moment of this
horrifying spectacle
all 15 had dropped dead to the concrete
like sacks of grain
as this was happening stephanie guthrie
stood as still as marble in the center
of the action
her outstretched hands like white wings
her expression as lifeless as that of a
china doll
when the police and then the ambulance
had come she had said nothing
reacted to nothing the emts who strapped
her onto the gurney said that she was
completely docile
but also entirely lacking in humanity
like an empty husk
since then her condition had not changed
vic took a swig of black coffee from his
thermos then settled it back into the
fork of his crotch
his dark mood was getting darker by the
minute
he thought of dr hill's mention of
terrorists that had been his first
thought too
but something about the situation didn't
sit right besides that a search of
stephanie guthrie's person had turned up
nothing resembling a container
in which the toxin could have been
carried and even her skin had only shown
trace amounts of the chemical that had
killed the others
it was all very odd whatever direction
the case was taking the department was
on his ass to put it to bed as quickly
as possible
and to that end he was skipping lunch
and driving up to hastings to interview
ms guthrie's parents
he hoped they could give him some
insight into her history her personality
from long experience though he knew this
wasn't likely he sighed and turned off
the highway
vic parked in front of a modest brick
townhouse and slid out of the car
he called the guthries yesterday to set
up the meeting and now as he walked up
the driveway he noticed the curtain
twitching as someone peered out at him
he pretended he hadn't seen his knock
was answered by a rail thin man in his
mid-60s
clean shaven with a slick bald head his
eyes were absent
green sharp and wary come in inspector
unger was it call me vic mr guthrie
thanks
vic passed over the threshold and
immediately spotted mrs guthrie who
stood nervously at the end of the hall
she was also in her 60s still fairly
youthful and fit
though the few lines on her face
appeared deep with worry
at mr guthrie's invitation vic took a
seat in the living room
choosing a worn upholstered chair near
the unlit fireplace
he noticed a framed photograph of
stephanie on the mantel and for a moment
he marveled at the difference between
the cheerful girl in the picture
and the sullen zombie he'd seen back at
the hospital
mrs guthrie offered tea which vic
politely refused
he waited until the couple had settled
themselves on the matching sofa across
from him
and then he got straight to the point
let me just say that i want nothing more
than to see that stephanie gets the help
she needs mr and mrs guthrie he began
as i'm sure you're aware the situation
is very grave
15 people are dead and it appears that
stephanie may somehow be involved
as either a victim or a perpetrator as i
told you on the phone she is refusing or
unable to speak
so anything you can tell me would be
greatly appreciated
he pulled a tiny tape recorder from his
jacket pocket may i
the couple murmured ascent and he
switched it on
mrs guthrie's lower lip was trembling i
just don't understand how any of this
could have happened she said
stephanie never hurt anyone and she
would never do anything to hurt rey
she adored him mr guthrie was nodding in
agreement
yes there must be some mistake i'm sure
she was just the victim of a horrible
attack
or perhaps a freak accident that's what
we're hoping to find out
vic said with a tight smile please
forgive me but i have to ask some of
these questions
now about rey they were engaged correct
yes
had they been having any problems though
arguments had her behavior seemed any
different recently
mr guthrie was shaking his head before
vic had even finished speaking
we just saw the both of them on friday
night they came over for dinner
nothing was wrong they were happy
laughing talking about the wedding plans
i just can't believe stephanie would
have anything to do with anything so
horrible mrs guthrie said
her eyes were glistening but she spoke
firmly the poor deer
especially after yvonne mr guthrie
bellowed
vic fixed each of them with a hard stare
especially after what
nothing inspector said mr guthrie my
wife was just going to say
especially after we had just seen her
the day before he shot ivan a warning
look that he probably thought vic didn't
notice
george she reached out and touched the
back of his hand
vic's impatience was beginning to flare
up again it won't help your daughter's
case if you keep information from me
he said trying to tone down the
irritation in his voice
she's not our daughter mrs guthrie said
with a defiant glance toward her husband
i thought you might have found that out
by now yvonne i told you
vic put up his hand to silence mr
guthrie who was clearly approaching a
meltdown
let your wife talk sir he doesn't like
to talk about it said mrs guthrie
patting her husband's hand again
it was his brother and sister-in-law you
know mr guthrie looked ready to explode
but vic preempted him with a calming
gesture go on mrs guthrie
it was such a long time ago stephanie
was only about 10 at the time
yvonne said a very bright child she was
we didn't see her often back then you
understand
her parents that's george's brother and
sister-in-law lived in rosemary about 90
miles north of here
but we saw them on holidays of course
vic wondered if this story would be
going anywhere relevant but he leaned
forward in his seat
silently encouraging her to continue
well it happened at stephanie's school
yvonne said she glanced over at george
who had covered his face with his hands
it was one of those open house nights
you know where the parents come to meet
the teachers and so on
do you have any children inspector vic
did
a baby son but he shook his head no he
didn't want mrs guthrie getting
sidetracked
well it was the funniest thing yvonne
continued to vic's relief
not funny of course but strange i don't
think anyone ever figured out exactly
what happened
it was all so sudden one minute there
were kids and parents milling around the
classroom
looking at all the projects the children
had made and then the next minute
mrs guthrie waved her hand vaguely in
the air her bottom lip was trembling
again
i wasn't there you understand she said
her voice going hoarse
but i heard all about it the paper said
there was blood everywhere
covering everything and all those poor
little children
the tears finally came and yvonne
pressed her hands to her lips
an indication that she could not
continue
vic looked to mr guthrie who looked
haggardly back at him
what happened vic asked they all died
what do you think happened
george rasped my brother and
sister-in-law some other parents
teachers a bunch of kids almost everyone
in the room as a matter of fact
stephanie and one other person were the
only ones who survived
but what killed them vic urged
exasperated was it a shooting
mrs guthrie had recovered enough to
speak again i told you they didn't know
what it was
everyone just dropped dead near as i can
figure from the news stories
no one was shot they were sure of that
but she trailed off shrugging
i guess they didn't have all the fancy
forensic science they have nowadays
anyway it was in all the papers back
then the rosemary gazette a couple of
others
she sniffed and wiped at her nose primly
with a handkerchief she had produced
from her pocket
vic made a mental note to check the
archives for news stories about the
deaths
he didn't remember hearing about it at
the time but he hadn't been much older
than stephanie then
and he doubted that any news story no
matter how bizarre would have made its
way into his teenage psyche all those
years ago
was stephanie questioned after all this
happened he asked
mr and mrs guthrie looked at each other
there was a long pause then yvonne
finally said
she was never the same afterwards her
voice was so soft that vic had to lean
further forward to hear her
she just kind of vanished into herself
not surprising i suppose after such a
trauma
george and i got custody we were the
closest relatives you know
and we were happy to do it but we
couldn't reach the girl
she had to be hospitalized for a while
yvonne looked as though she might be on
the verge of losing it again but she
clenched her jaw and held herself
together
how long was she hospitalized mrs
guthrie vic had lowered his voice to
match hers
oh almost two years i think it was she
sounded almost apologetic
as though the girl's illness was a
personal failing i hated to see her in
there i really did but
well what else could we do they did help
her in that hospital right enough
mr guthrie added stephanie was never the
same as before but once she came out of
there she was much better
not like she was but still okay now it
looked as though george might break down
crying again
vic thought he had caused the couple
enough anguish for one day so he
switched off the recorder
replaced it in his pocket and stood to
go
thanks very much mr mrs guthrie he said
reaching out to shake their hands
i'll be in touch and if you think of
anything more give me a call
we certainly will vic left the pair to
their heartbreak
and made his way back to his car where
he finished off the thermos of now
lukewarm coffee
his earlier hesitancy it seemed had been
wrong he had obtained quite a bit of
interesting information from stephanie's
adoptive parents
and now it seemed like the reticent miss
guthrie wasn't quite as above suspicion
as she at first appeared
teresa hill locked her office door
behind her then retraced her well-worn
steps down the hall to stephanie
guthrie's room
it had been four days since the incident
and very little progress had been made
the woman was easily the most difficult
case she'd ever run across
and as such was maddeningly
stephanie had not moved during teresa's
absence
the doctor fetched a chair from an
adjacent room and placed it a few feet
from stephanie then closed the door
perhaps hypnosis was the only way to
reach the patient dr hill mused
certainly nothing else had worked teresa
had tried cajoling and threatening
withholding food
appealing to stephanie's love for her
family and her dead fiancee
the woman had sat through it all stoic
emotionless
she wasn't completely out of it teresa
knew she had been eating a little
and could be counted upon to get up and
use the bathroom when necessary
but beyond that she was a shell of a
person an automaton
teresa started today's session as she
had begun the others talking to
stephanie in low tones
addressing her frequently by name in
order to place focus on her core
identity
as with all the other times stephanie
did not react not even to make fleeting
eye contact with the doctor
after about 15 minutes of this teresa
sighed and stop
talking clearly it was time for a
different approach
one she had been putting off for days
she reached into the pocket of her coat
and drew out the small metronome she had
brought from her office
she got up and placed it on the seat of
her chair she turned it on
and its winking silver needle began to
tick back and forth
with a sound like a wooden cane tapping
on pavement
i don't know if you can hear me or
understand me stephanie said dr hill
standing off to the side with her hands
clasped behind her back
but if you can i want you to look at the
object in front of you
concentrate on it very hard and ignore
everything else but it and the sound of
my voice
teresa had no idea whether stephanie was
complying or not
since her blank expression did not
change she pressed on
good just keep looking at it focusing on
the needle going back and forth
back and forth again there was no
discernable reaction but teresa
continued on
allowing her voice to become softer and
softer until it was a pleasant drone in
the drab
room at last she said now stephanie
i want you to close your eyes for a long
moment nothing happened
and teresa's hopes began to fade perhaps
they would never be able to reach the
woman
perhaps the bizarre deaths at the zoo
would remain forever unsolved
then stephanie's eyes fluttered closed
teresa almost leaped for joy but managed
to keep her voice
level even as her heart hammered against
her rib cage
very good stephanie now i want you to go
back to last saturday
the day you and rey went to the zoo do
you remember
stephanie didn't answer but her brow
furrowed as though she just heard some
troubling news
teresa was so elated to see a change in
expression that she immediately moved on
to the next question
what happened that day stephanie can you
tell me
the patient's frown deepened and her
eyelids began to twitch
teresa thought she saw the woman shake
her head ever so slightly
but it might have been wishful thinking
can you tell me what happened stephanie
dr hill persisted trying mightily to
keep from badgering her
you were walking along with rey weren't
you there were some other people around
and then what two tears squeezed from
beneath stephanie's closed lids
and trickled down her cheeks her face
was a mask of horror and sorrow
and teresa considered waking her up
right then but at that moment stephanie
began to move
her arms which had been dangling loosely
by her sides started to rise
almost as though they were attached to a
puppeteer's strings
stephanie's eyes remained closed but her
face contorted
seemingly fighting against the actions
of the rest of her body
her arms were now outstretched level
with her shoulders
and as theresa watched the woman
unfurled her fingers like flower petals
and spread them wide the doctor opened
her mouth to ask what she was doing
but then stephanie's eyes flew open and
her gaze fixed fully on teresa
the zombie stare now replaced by a look
of frightening hyper-aware intensity
the doctor backed up a step the voice
said stephanie the words little more
than a creak of muscles long unused
dr hill was so shocked that the patient
had spoken that she stumbled over the
next question and had to repeat it
whose voice stephanie she asked trying
to maintain contact with that unsettling
stare
what did it say stephanie's eyes widened
becoming round black holes in the midst
of her ghostly visage
there was a sound from behind but teresa
ignored it intent upon her patient's
words
lepidoptera stephanie said and then her
entire body seemed to collapse in on
itself
her arms dropping back to her sides her
head falling forward
until her chin rested on her chest blood
came
first in a trickle and then in a torrent
frantically teresa clapped her hands
attempting to wake the patient from the
hypnotic trance but the sharp sounds of
her palms smacking together had no
effect
other than producing a flat echo against
the gray concrete walls
vicks stomped on the gas urging the car
to go faster
even though he was already exceeding the
speed limit by a considerable margin
he hoped to christ his hunch was wrong
but a sick feeling in the pit of his
stomach suggested it wasn't
in fact if dr hill had gone ahead with
the planned hypnosis
then it was probably already too late
after leaving the guthries the day
before yesterday
vic had gone straight to the rosemary
library and spent the better part of the
afternoon examining the newspaper
archives on microfilm
and there just as mrs guthrie had stated
was the entire unbelievable story
laid out in all its puzzling detail
though stephanie being a minor was not
mentioned by name
police at the time had been mystified
and even though vic had scoured the
later records hoping for some follow-up
he had found nothing further other than
a short article a few months after the
event which speculated that the deaths
had been caused by some freak chemical
seepage into the classroom
since the victims had apparently all
succumbed to some unknown poisonous
fumes
just like the 15 people at the zoo bick
had thought grimly
only one other person had survived the
accident 12 years before
and that was a young teacher by the name
of bill travers
vic had spent the previous day tracking
the man down only to find out that he
had died in an institution
having been in a near comatose state for
nearly 10 years following the occurrence
at the school open house
and after speaking to one of the older
nurses who still worked at the hospital
where travers had died
vic discovered something else that when
a doctor had attempted hypnosis in order
to reach the poor man
travers had ended up dead the doctor
catatonic
examination of mr travers had revealed
that his death was caused by the same
mysterious chemical that had killed the
parents and children in the classroom
and the same one vic knew that it killed
the 15 people at the zoo last week
he'd had a report back from the lab boys
on that too
they had no idea what the substance was
other than that it was sort of like a
pheromone
but deadly poisonous yeah tell me
something i don't know
vick had said sardonically but there was
a minor detail that nagged at vic
the nurse at the institution where
travers had breathed his last
had supplied him with a grainy black and
white videotape of the hypnosis session
where travers had died
the similarity with stephanie's case was
chilling as the man sat very still in
his chair
seemingly incense it as the doctor stood
over him
and toning a list of questions that was
meant to draw him out of his traumatized
state
but suddenly the man's eyes had opened
his face had wrenched apart in a silent
scream
and he had uttered a single word
lepidoptera
the tape stopped just as his lifeless
body slithered to the floor
vick blew through a yellow light that
turned red the second he passed under it
he didn't understand exactly what the
mechanisms behind all this were but the
outcome seemed abundantly clear
something was causing these people to
transform from normal functioning human
beings into
what was it some kind of killer virus
triggered by environmental factors
or even by some internal apparatus that
lay dormant in the body
until a particular moment caused it to
flower
vic didn't know but he did know that
both stephanie guthrie and teresa hill
were in horrible danger
even though he had abandoned the idea of
god long ago he began reciting a litany
in his head
something like a prayer though to who or
what he was praying he couldn't have
said
please let it not be too late please let
it not be too late
after what seemed like hours of driving
the unobtrusive sign identifying the
mayflower psychiatric hospital loomed
through his windshield
he turned the car without slowing down
feeling two tires leave the ground
and then tore down the long tree-lined
road that led to the parking lot
he pulled abruptly to the curb and
leaped from the car leaving the door
wide open
and the keys dangling in the ignition
doctors and nurses turned to stare at
him as he belted down the halls
flashing his badge at anyone who looked
as though they may try to stop him
squeezing through the digitally locked
doors the second the shocked guards had
opened them
his shoes squeaked on the linoleum and
his lungs were filled with the mingled
odors of urine and sweat and
formaldehyde
he headed first for dr hill's office but
saw immediately that she was not there
his heart sinking he continued running
down the endless corridors
deeper into the bowels of the hospital
at last he arrived at stephanie
guthrie's room
he turned the knob and found it unlocked
which made his hopes dim even further
he was almost afraid of what he would
see as he pushed open the door
for a split second it appeared that
everything was fine
dr hill was standing in the middle of
the room leaning towards stephanie
who sat in the chair she had barely
moved from for several days
her eyes closed her arms outstretched
an echo hung in the air as though dr
hill had just asked a question that
awaited an answer
just as vic was about to speak and
announce his presence stephanie's eyes
opened and fixed on the doctors
her lips parted with a soft clip vic
darted into the room
knowing what she was about to say but
for some reason time seemed to have
slowed
the way it does in dreams stephanie
seemed very far away
her mouth opening like a tiny black o
lepidoptera
she said and then her entire frame
collapsed and blood began to ooze from
her nose and mouth
as vic watched she crumpled to the floor
her eyes already beginning to glaze over
the single words she had spoken humming
around the enclosed space like a
hell-bent mosquito
dr hill was clapping her hands obviously
trying to awaken a patient that would
wake no more
she still had not noticed vic at all she
moved towards stephanie
and then vic felt it that word the woman
had whispered
tunneling into his brain like an
earthworm through the loam
lodging in the deepest part of him he
could feel it radiating outward from
this command center
infecting his flesh his entire molecular
structure
he could feel it squirming within him
using him for its own devilish purposes
waiting for the moment when it would
unleash itself upon the unwary
making of him an unwitting carrier
accomplice slaughterer
dr hill finally turned and saw him
standing there
and just before his brain began its
inevitable withdrawal into its cocoon
he managed to lock gazes with her she
had fallen to her knees next to the
corpse of her patient
clearly suffering the same appalling
fate as he
vic tried to smile at her if only to
show that they were now joined in their
shared contagion
but he couldn't quite do it at last he
felt his body falling
and his thin veneer of rationality
dissolved completely
his thumping heart keeping time with the
ticking beat of the metronome
you